jean marc bonjour merci de nous avoir
rejoints sur la matinale de rtl france
alors selon la banque de france
l'économie française aura perdu presque
11% de richesse sur 2020 avec une
prévision de 1021 de rebond plus faible
que ce qu'on a prévoyait à 5 ou 6% ce
qui nous permet pas d'espérer un
récupérer le niveau d'avant qu'ovide
jean marc sylvestre on pense à 2021
pourrait effacer des dégâts 2020 or on
n'y arrivera pas expliqué nous pour
quelles raisons
ça peut repartir mais assez tard écoutez
c'est simple personne n'a le prévu quand
on a fait toutes les prévisions
la deuxième vague on est sorti du
premier confinement en mai avec un
sentiment d'euphorie vous vous souvenez
l'économie avait beaucoup souffert
pendant le premier confinement puisqu'on
avait perdu au deuxième trimestre 80% de
l'activité ça a été un désastre puisque
toutes été arrêtées mais tout le monde
avait envie de se rattraper et tout le
monde a rebondi très fortement un peu
comme on est au fond de la piscine et
bien on est reparti je suis fait que
septembre est là bas on pensait avoir
limité les dégâts sur l'année
malheureusement le virus lui aussi est
rentré de vacances et voilà on a
commencé à déchanter avec le 2ème
confinement on a été un peu moins dur ce
qui concerne les restrictions
d'économique mais on avait aussi appris
à gérer tout ça les entreprises avaient
avait s'était adaptée elle avait muté et
puis on avait assumé sauf que des
secteurs entiers ne sont pas repartis le
tourisme l'hôtellerie les transports
l'aéronautique
on connaît tous à l'événementiel bien
sûr le cinéma le théâtre et puis le
commerce le commerce était reparti bien
sûr mais le couvre-feu depuis hier soir
20 heures a encore bloquée une reprise
que les commerçants espéraient booster
avec notamment les nocturnes qu'ils ont
l'habitude de faire au moment des fêtes
de noël bat c'est fini par se voir
fermer les boutiques à 7h 7h30 donc
globalement on va encore faire près de
10% en novembre et en décembre sur
l'année la perte de richesse détruite va
être vous le disiez 11% selon les
statistiques officielles c'est la
moyenne européenne d'ailleurs les
allemands vont faire un peu mieux que
nous les italiens les espagnols ils vont
faire beaucoup plus mal donc pour 21
eh bien on va partir de très bas on aura
du mal à rebondir autant on table sur un
rebond de 6% au milieu maximum en france
ça veut dire qu'à la fin de l'année
prochaine fait le calcul
eh bien on sera encore en dessous de la
normale saisonnière comme disent les
météos
c'est à dire à -5% par rapport à ce que
on avait avant le coc vide
il faudra donc encore attendre presque
le courant de 2022 peut-être même la fin
2022 pour retrouver les niveaux
d'équilibré alors et pour 2021 qu'elle
songe aux marques les facteurs
d'inquiétude ce qui pèse beaucoup sur
l'activité il ya des facteurs de risque
qui sont objectifs dont on parle pas
trop mais il va bien falloir bien sûr
que c'était le problème les banques
notamment qui ont distribué beaucoup de
crédit beaucoup de moratoire aussi c'est
à dire qu'on a permis un certain nombre
d'acteurs de l'économie notamment les
collectivités locales ou ou surtout les
entreprises de ne pas payer à échéance
leurs dettes on risque d'avoir un
problème sur les marchés boursiers c'est
que les marchés boursiers sont à peu
près bien tenu a pendant 2021
il commence à avoir des inquiétudes
maintenant pour sion bienvenue en 2020
pardon il commence à voir les
inquiétudes pour deux pour 2021 donc si
on ne risque pas d'accident bancaire
parce que on surveille beaucoup mais si
jamais il y avait il y avait un problème
de ce côté-là ça risquerait de casser à
nouveau la confiance il ya des
entreprises qui était très malade avant
le coc vide qui se retrouveront dans le
coma après le coc vide c'est à dire
l'année prochaine il va donc falloir
gérer la disparition ou les difficultés
de très grosses entreprises
certains plans sociaux ont sont déjà
sortis et ils font très mal
il va surtout falloir gérer la
disparation d'une multitude de petites
et moyennes entreprises qui sont très
fragiles et qui vivait beaucoup à grâce
aux aides publiques c'est le cas par
exemple des cafés restaurants là à peu
près 100 à 150 mille établissements
cafés restaurants fragile qui vont avoir
du mal à passer l'année 2021 doc risque
social derrière tout ça autres risques
l'international il faut que le monde
entier redémarre ce n'est pas gagné les
transports aériens sont toujours au
ralenti les transports maritimes aussi
il faut pas exclure et on n'en parle pas
mais risque cyber oui la période
actuelle favorise des attaques des
systèmes informatiques les
trop triste qui sont en sont victimes
n'en parle pas trop parce que pour leur
image ce serait déplorable mais ça fait
peur à tout le monde et des assureurs
sont de ce côté là très inquiet j'ajoute
les risques politiques
on voit bien que toutes les démocraties
sont fragilisés par tout en europe
parlez pas de l'endettement colossal des
états non c'est vrai alors à priori ça
peut faire peur en france notamment
parce que ça représente 120% de notre
richesse c'est colossal c'est la
première fois dans l'histoire mais dans
la pratique on est en train de s'y
habituer à peu près dans tous les pays
occidentaux ces dettes ne coûte pas très
cher paradoxalement puisque elle
rapporte de l'argent
les taux d'intérêt sont négatifs savez
vous que chaque fois que la france
emprunte à l'extérieur pour pouvoir
financer les aides qu'elle dit qu'elle
distribue et bien elle gagne de l'argent
on a gagné à peu près presque 3
milliards l'année dernière avec le
montant colossal des dates que nietzsche
comme ça on fait pourquoi mais parce que
nous qui sommes des épargnants eh bien
nous payons finalement quelque part un
impôt négatif taux négatifs nous payons
pour que cet argent soit protégée soit
sécurisé ça veut dire quoi
ça veut dire que les épargnants du monde
entier ont encore confiance dans les
états occidentaux pour pouvoir gérer le
problème cette dette à très long terme
est bien bien sûr il faudra là il faudra
la rembourser
mais ce sera dans très longtemps donc à
ce moment là eh bien on aura retrouvé
sans doute de la croissance et à ce
moment là on aura peut-être les moyens
de réemprunter pour rembourser la dette
précédent c'est pas ce souci premier
urgent est en amour que faudrait-il
faire que faudrait-il faire c'est un
hameau le vaccin dire que le vaccin est
en deux mots je dirais la vaccination
campagne de vaccination c'est la seule
chose qui peut ramener véritablement à
confiance avait beaucoup parlé et on
voit bien que le vaccin a changé un peu
le moral améliorer le moral mais que le
vaccin est porteur de défiance au sida
d'inquiétude la vaccination va durer
plus qu'on ne le pensait elle va sur
notre durée plus d'un an
le problème essentiel est un problème de
confiance
merci beaucoup jean marc sylvestre
éditorialiste économique pour rt france